- [Narrator] Why is the
Speaker second in succession
to the President after the Vice President?
- The idea of succession actually
it was a little muddied
and it wasn't until
the 25th amendment that actually
the relationship between the President
and the Vice President
was actually formalized.
When William Henry Harrison died
and John Tyler came in,
his Vice President as President
there was a big debate about whether
he was actually really the President.
So, even though the line of
succession is written down
there's a lot of debate about whether
what enforces it and what doesn't.
The Speaker of the House
though has prominence
in that line of succession because
the Speaker of the House
is closest to the people
and the formation of
the federal government.
Article one defines the powers of Congress
because the framers wanted Congress
really to be the powerful branch,
close to the people.
They were worried about a monarchy.
So they didn't want the President to have
excessive power and the
Speaker of the House represents
all of the, is elected
by all of the members
and so has a closer
relationship to the people
and that's what gives them power
in the question of succession.
What's interesting though is that there's
only been one Speaker of the House
who's then gone on to be President,
James K. Polk.
So while they are high up
in the order of succession
behind the Vice President,
that doesn't necessarily make the job
a stepping stone to actual
power of the presidency
through the electoral process.